[Music]
[Applause]
Drex here from Drex Factor po sharing
with you the love of pois spinning and
flow Arts to benefit your body and brain
in today I'm going to show you how to
use those stalls regardless of what your
skill level is but before we dive in I
just want to give a quick shout out to
the Friends of the channel big thanks to
dark monk fire Mecca flow fests flow
toys juggling calling pirate ter light
toys spinballs and Ultra poy for helping
to make the videos on this channel
possible you can learn more about all
these awesome companies and the work
that they're doing to support flow
artists like yourself by checking out
the links down in the description of
this video and special thanks to the
non- buus friend of the channel Becca
Becken thank you so very much for
supporting my channel my work and my
mission stalls can be used for
transitions for accents and even to
create beautiful po patterns in their
own right regardless of what skill level
you're at as a pois spinner I can
guarantee you that there is a pattern or
trick that uses stalls that is going to
be a perfect fit for your flow and while
this list is far from comprehensive
these are five specific uses for stalls
that I found are a good fit at a variety
of different skill levels so let me take
you through them level one beginner down
stalls of course my preferred method for
learning all stalls is to think of them
as sitting inside of the stall box that
is you can think of the PO as it spins
around as forming a circle and a box
sitting around that Circle whenever you
perform a stall what you're really doing
is you're letting the PO hit the corners
of that box this will be true whether
you're doing down stalls up stalls
bottom stalls or top stalls and down
stalls definitely become a Gateway into
learning these techniques even better
than that they will help you transition
back and forth between different poy
tricks whether you're trying to get back
and forth between tricks in wheel and
wall plane or you're trying to get
between different timing and Direction
modes you'll find that down stalls are a
great fit for allowing you to be able to
pause for a second think about what
you're doing and then reverse the
direction of the PO if you so choose and
if you'd like to hear more about my
approach to learning all stalls
including the down stall I will go ahead
and leave a link to my video on the
stall box down in the description as
well as up in the cards but how about we
find ways of applying those down stalls
and maybe adding some other stalls into
the mix too level two beginner
intermediate stall Chasers I think stall
Chasers are one of my favorite
applications for stall ever not only do
they require you to know multiple stalls
in order to complete them but also you
have to gain a level of nuance and
control over your momentum that is
really unique to this trick stall
Chasers involve both entering and
exiting vertical stalls in such a way
that you're adding a lot of nuance and
momentum to the movement of the POI as
they perform these two actions
specifically you're looking to carry
both POI over the top of your head in
such a way that they form a perfect
horizontal line in between the two
stalls and this requires you not only to
to gain an enormous amount of control
over the entry and exit points of the
Stalls but also the momentum of the POI
as it's going between them as well you
can then use these to go back and forth
in Split Time same direction moves like
windmills or into things like meltdowns
really this is a great transition tool
and a great POI pattern definitely worth
learning as you can already see stalls
are really important not just as a
transition tool but also for creating
great patterns with the POI and that
takes us to number three intermediate
horizontal stacking where stall Chasers
only required us to know how to perform
up and down stalls stacking requires us
to know all of the Stalls and most
importantly the most challenging stall
of all the top stall this particular
stack is one that I refer to as the Mel
after Ivan Mel gorinov the tech po
spinner who first showed it off in his
video red pants more than a decade ago I
consider this to be the start of an
entire movement of different POI
patterns called horizontal stacks and
this is still my favorite of that family
performing horizontal Stacks like the
Mel requires us not only to gain Mastery
over our ability to do top stalls but
also to synchronize them with other
movements by synchronizing those top
stalls with our pendulums we get several
different moments where we get the POI
aligned in these perfect horizontal
lines those horizontal lines themselves
are really useful for exploring
everything from hybrids to plane brakes
and a variety of other different
transitions too but it does also have to
be said that not all po stalls conform
to something that works inside of that
stall box that I outlined in our first
entry and that takes us to number four
intermediate Advanced Point isolation
stalls so while on the surface of it
these might not look exactly like what
we classically consider to be stalls
they absolutely have the same function
and in the grand scheme of things they
exhibit so many similarities that one
could think of them as kind of being
stalls turned inside out Point isolation
stalls are usually performed out of
pendulums as the POI gets up to hand
height on either side you can have the
hand then swing directly over the PO
head and Bre it to a complete stop and
while this requires a very different set
of kinesthetic experiences namely being
able to bring the hand around the PO
head in a point isolation it also does
still fundamentally have the same
structure as a traditional stall believe
it or not the only real difference
between how a point isolation stall
works and a traditional down stall works
is where the movement of the hand is
situated really you can just as easily
drop the poy head down whenever it
reaches either side of the pendulum
simply by moving the hand straight out
to the position that the head once
occupied really all we're doing is
taking the hands movement and switching
it from a straight line to a quarter of
a circle so before I reveal to you our
final level of Po stalls I do have a
favor to ask if you've come this far it
probably means that you have an interest
in petrix and maybe pois spinning in
general and if that's the case please
subscribe to the channel so that you can
see all the new videos that I produce on
these topics when they come out please
and thank you and now for my final pick
level five of Po stalls we have level
five Advanced
Splats so what's harder than stalling
just one PO with your hand why it's
stalling two POI with just one hand the
word Splats is something that I got from
John Alvarez many many years ago and the
idea is that you're trying to take the
same idea as a POI stall and apply it to
both POI at the same time generally
having them stall in opposite directions
and if you think about it this is kind
of The Logical extension of the stall
boox exercise that I explained in our
first level Nam if you can get your hand
to move perfectly to the side of that
box then you should be able to perform
stalls to either corner of it
simultaneously of course it's much
easier said than done to be able to
perform Splats in this way and what a
lot of people have done is actually take
this into threo territory and perform
stalls with three POI pointing 120° off
of each other simultaneously regardless
of how you perform your Splats they are
without a doubt the most difficult
application for pools that I have ever
encountered in my entire career and that
is why they at the top of this list what
are some of the most difficult
applications for stalls that you have
found please leave me a comment and let
me
[Music]
know this video is made possible by my
awesome supporters on patreon in
particular I'd love to give a shout out
to my flow patrons who are listed on
screen right now if you enjoy the
content that I produce videos and
tutorials about Po and POI spinning you
can help me make them by heading on over
and signing up over at
patreon.com drexfactor poo there you can
get access to a whole host of awesome
rewards and even better than that
support me in my mission to bring po
spinning and flow Arts to the whole wide
world go check that out please and thank
you and if you'd like to explore more
skill level challenges with various
different po tricks I have a video on
five different levels of Po isolations
that'll go and link to up on screen here
as well as down in the description maybe
check that one out next thanks so much
for watching make sure to get out and
flow today and I'll see you with a new
video real soon take care now peace